[Music]
hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
battle royale has had yet another huge
update from the outside it may just seem
like it's a christmas event but it goes
much deeper than that
let's quickly have a look through 11 new
things brought in in patch 1.1 one
visually the biggest change is the
Christmas theme running through the
world trees and bushes are now
surrounded by Christmas lights and the
grenade launcher has had a new skin and
new animations added to create a
snowball launcher that will bring a
little festive cheer to your explosive
murder sprees the battle bus has also
had a visual overhaul spreading a little
more Christmas cheer but this isn't the
best thing about the new update it's all
about season 2 running between December
14th to February 20th season 2 will
allow players to unlock rewards as they
gain experience points at regular level
intervals cosmetic items are rewarded
these will be vanity items and shouldn't
change the game in any fundamental way
here's the best bit though those of us
who don't have the cash to put into
battle royale can still unlocked vanity
items to stand out from the crowd so you
shouldn't see the exact same Roman
reigns or Halle Berry in every single
fight this will also make it easy for
everyone to track who you are fighting
those of us with the base game can earn
VIII bucks to unlock the rewards in the
premium section just below the free
section and of course if you've got zero
control and a credit card you could buy
everything for real pounds real dollars
or real euros expect to be given a small
amount of ebooks in the free levels to
give you a taste of spending them on
premium gear of course the publisher
wants your money and hopes to [ __ ] you
early on oh and I think we should look
at the small print to future seasons
we'll be real money star purchases
fingers crossed those people who bought
the founder's pack won't be shafted in
future seasons time will tell I suppose
to be eligible for the premium content
you will require a battle pass which
will be half-price for season two coming
in at 950 bucks
this will unlock the premium content
you'll be grinding towards there's a
pretty cool item
receive right away the blue Squire
outfit looks mighty impressive and in
addition to this you will get an extra
daily challenge slot alongside other XP
boosts from that point your only job is
to play the hell out of fox night battle
royale and earn those rewards which
range from gliders freakin brilliant
harvesting tools and even the occasional
emote okay I admit it I really want this
emot-- the backpack kid is my hero he's
everyone's hero isn't he
there's more than 65 unlockable items to
get your hands on over the season which
ends on February 20th the devs put the
amount of time needed to unlock all
these items at between 75 and 150 hours
of in-game massacring and building if
you've got the V bucks you can unlock
everything immediately I was thinking
about buying all the vanity items to
showcase them in a video but I kind of
feel that might be a bit click of a T
let me know your thoughts and I'll
definitely consider it the patch notes
also reveal a plethora of mini changes
to the game let's fly through them as
quickly as possible a new sliding
animation has been added in an attempt
to fix the issue with mountain surfing
it's only a first step so the random
damage you may take will probably still
be around for a few months yet who is a
good one grenade throws now have a
trajectory path overlaid for Rd
precision very much needed indeed any
new players coming to Battle Royale will
be given the combat pro controller type
as a default but don't worry if you
don't use this whatever you currently
have set in game will remain that way
have you ever had that issue where you
shoot someone in the head with a shotgun
and it only takes off six health from
their stack very annoying isn't it well
incorrect damage figures are being
patched out so maybe just maybe that
will happen a little less now another
quality of life improvement comes in the
shape of those loot chests that you see
from a distance that seem to be
completely intact but then you walk
closer and they suddenly pop open and
you've wasted your time this shouldn't
happen at all anymore it's been patched
out halle-bloody-lujah
legendary assault rifles have a 25% less
chance of being found in the open now so
supply drops will once again be your
main focus for high quality gear again
oh here's another one for all you
console gamers the aim assist on snipers
has been removed allowing you to track
and lead your target for better headshot
accuracy
oh one more last thing and it's the
biggest thing you can ever imagine
footballs and basketballs now bounce and
roll much smoother so set up a makeshift
Court or go to the football field and
enjoy a bit of a kick around and there
we have it 11 new things in Fox night
battle royale patch 1.07 are 1.11 how do
you say it anyway please let me know if
you're thinking of buying the battle
pass and what you think about future
seasons being all about real money I'm
not sure about that one I'm Adam from
Playstation grenade have a freaking
brilliant Christmas and I'll see you
soon it's been a pleasure see you next
time